[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online julianne hough and her gal pals
took to social media to share their
awesome vacay celebrating Jules's
bachelorette party which included BFF
nina dobrev and Aaron Paul's wife Lauren
the hashtag final hurrah consisted of
partying on a catamaran and these
hilarious slo-mo shots in the pool I
love that Kim Kourtney and Khloe
Kardashian went on assisters getaway to
Palm Springs over the weekend and shared
all of the fun moments to Instagram and
snapchat being silly in their hotel room
taking a drive and visiting the famous
Palm Springs dinosaurs Maksim
Chmerkovskiy adorably danced his way
through the streets with his two month
old son shy he posted that adorable
video to the gram of daddy time writing
been waiting for this for the longest
time I'm so excited
Candace Cameron Bure channeled her full
house character while shopping over the
weekend sharing this selfie of her
rocking some old-school jeans joking in
the caption I'm legit DJ Tanner straight
out of the 90s meanwhile Mel B revealed
her father Martin Brown died at age 63
on Saturday posting this sweet photo
holding his hand captioning it in Part V
free dad